what is the purpose of language like
people with periods
or pregnant people why does this
inclusiveness make me so angry
why is gender identity not provable and
affects less than one percent replacing
sex
yeah you're not alone you're not alone
you're being gaslit
yeah you're being gaslit i will say um i
don't know where all we're gonna go but
i
um abigail schreier who
wrote the recent book
and i can't remember the name of it i
should i'll i'll show it next time we're
on
um about the rapid onset gender
dysphoria that seems to be happening to
teenage girls specifically
um as a contagion in teenage girls
um she and i have just begun a uh
a letter wiki exchange about what is
happening
specifically over um you know the focus
she she
made the initial missive in in letter
wiki
um about what's happening to teenage
girls and and
what we can attribute these this these
contagions
to um with regard to like comparing them
to comparing
human females to non-human primates and
you know what what friendships among
non-human primate females have looked
like um
the question more broadly of
why gender identity is replacing sex is
exactly i think that's spot on in terms
of
the question that um why do we even call
it why do we call it gender dysphoria
this isn't gender dysphoria gender is
the behavioral manifestation of sex
and every other species gender exists
outside of humans it absolutely does
people who tell you it's a human
creation no they're wrong
we call it sex role and it is the
behavioral manifestation that is typical
for the sex that you were born to
so gender dysphoria that's just like
being a tomboy
but that's not what gender dysphoria
especially is understood by
uh you know by the psychological
therapeutic manuals
is understanding to be what what they
really mean is
sex dysphoria and calling it gender
dysphoria is part of the confusion
now add to that people with periods and
pregnant people
and yeah this is this is gaslighting and
it's regressive
and it's misogynistic and it's nasty
and it all comes in this cloak of aren't
we loving and inclusive and no you're
not
so why does it make you so angry it's
because you're being manipulated and
you're being manipulated
by a threat and the problem is you know
um megan murphy is no longer on twitter
because she insisted that men weren't
women right
how dare she that's a measure of threat
and the idea of well
certainly you're supportive of trans
people yes
well if you're supportive of trans
people then you're supportive of
trans women competing in women's sports
no ah transphobe okay certainly you're
supportive of black lives matter
well i know that black lives do matter
well then you're supportive of
abolishing the nuclear family aren't you
right no exactly so at some level
the idea that um some men have periods
for example
this is designed to out you it's
designed to get you to either submit
or to say something that will allow you
to be stigmatized
and the point is you don't have a choice
outside of those so of course you're
angry to be
asked a question where those are your
two options you're damned if you do and
damned if you don't
um yeah it's an attempt to categorize
and stigmatize
well the point is look i don't care
which thing you say right
some men have periods right you know and
then it's like well
no ah failure mode a yes um
join the club um so
okay heads i win tails you lose has
never been a very good game
and this is that and so really i'm
getting at
is we are at the conversation that has
no content
right what what is the claim that some
men have periods
except for a delineator of whether
you are going to submit or uh
be hunted as a witch that's that's its
purpose is to get you to declare a side
its purpose is not to assert something
factual which was is what it sounds like
it is it's a factual claim that isn't a
factual claim
so that that's all true and that may be
the most
that's at least one of the most
important pieces of it um but it is
having ramifications
in the real world on our young people
that is going to create um a significant
fraction of a whole generation that is
going to be extraordinarily damaged
i saw uh i saw a picture in the last
week
of someone at some protest presumably
you know one of the protests that's
happening right now that is
you know supposedly about uh police
brutality and black lives matter and all
of this
the sign said puberty is optional
puberty is optional no it's
not yeah these people are so wrong
they are so confused i don't think the
person holding that sign was
intentionally gaslighting anyone they
had been gaslit themselves
and they are unable to tell reality from
i don't even know what a unicorn yeah
well
um the the problem is this is all
uh part of a plan that involves
de-individuating you um distancing you
from your family unless they're willing
to come along
and be part of the revolution yeah and
it
moves through schools there was a very
interesting
disturbing thread you can find it on
benjamin boyce's
twitter where a public school
teacher was decrying the
fact that covid means that um
many of the conversations that would
have taken place inside the classroom
are now taking place
in a where you can't know whether family
members might be listening in
and that this is a threat to the social
justice work that this teacher
believes is essential and so really what
that means
is that they're so i didn't i didn't see
this but from what you just said
i can i can see what you just said
coming from a place of actual genuine
care as an educator
um this wasn't that okay but but let's
just let's just recognize that the idea
that uh teenagers want may want to be
able to have conversations
with people they recognize as adults who
actually know something about the world
but not with their own
not within their own families is you
know that you know being able to talk to
your
uh religious leader you know that there
is a history of this that
is honorable yeah but no this is captive
audience the point is you send your kid
to school
and that puts you in the hand puts the
kid in the hands of somebody who then
has them
by law as a captive audience to
manipulate them and to tell them things
like some men have periods and stuff
like this
and the fact is it's unacceptable
and your family has the right to tell
you actually you know what i don't know
why people are insane
but people are now saying insane stuff
regularly and it is important that you
retain your ability to think in a world
people saying insane stuff
all the time yeah and the idea that this
is going to be exposed because you may
be on a zoom call rather than in a
classroom where you're going to be
fed the received wisdom uh is
it's just creating um is revealing
the depth of depravity that is unfolding
in
in many schools